كانت هذه المياه العميقة ذات اللون الأخضر والأزرق في
يوم من الأيام مكان الاستحمام الحصري
للنبلاء الجورجيين ولكن لم
تعد تغوص بنفسك
[موسيقى].
الأخاديد المليئة بالشلالات
والكهوف الطبيعية التي تشكلت بمرور الوقت عن
طريق تدفق نهر أباتشا ،
نحتت مياه الجبال الباردة مسارًا عبر
الحجر الجيري الناعم لتكوين
عجائب طبيعية تكشف عند أدنى مستوى لها
آثارًا للحفريات الموجودة في الصخر.
انخفاض القدم من الشلال إلى
حوض سباحة أدناه
يربط الأجزاء العلوية والسفلية
من الوادي. يُعرف المسبح في المستوى السفلي
بمياهه الباردة حتى في
ذروة الصيف مما يجعله المكان المثالي
للاستمتاع بجمال الطبيعة.
تم تشجيعهم على القيام برحلة
بالقارب على طول المياه وإحاطة
أنفسهم بالهدوء في
الشلالات المتدفقة التي تفرض المنحدرات
والأشجار النحيلة المغطاة بالطحالب
يمكن العثور على مناظر رائعة إما من الماء
أو من مسارات المشي التي
تتقاطع في الوادي عبر الجسور ومنصات المشاهدة ، كما
أن المناخ شبه الاستوائي هنا يتأثر
بالهواء الدافئ الرطب من البحر الأسود مما
يخلق نظامًا بيئيًا فريدًا يسمح
للنباتات والحيوانات بالازدهار داخل
كانيون والذي لا يوجد في أي مكان آخر
في البلد ،
منطقة سامي غوريلا التي يوجد فيها مارتن
فيلي كانيون والتي تعتبر الآن
مركزًا لتذوق الطعام في البلاد كانت
تُعرف سابقًا باسم المركز الثقافي لجورجيا
، ويقع دير فيلي المثير للإعجاب
على أعلى تل يطل
كانت القرية بمثابة مركز
التعلم والإدارة الكتابيين
لقرون وتسعة أميال إلى الشمال
في قرية سيلكي نو دادا دياني ، وقد
بنت خلواتها الصيفية وأشادت
بوادي مارت فييلي
كمكان للاستحمام الشخصي ،
ومن السهل معرفة سبب هذه القصة الخيالية
المملكة المائية ببركها الصافية الرائعة
وشلالاتها السرية قد سحرت
الناس بالجينات  حصص
[موسيقى]